it was early morning when they entered
the axamos compound more than a hundred
jewish settlers
escorted by israeli forces it was the
first time they were allowed in
since may 4th palestinians under the age
of 45 were barred from entering the
complex
well before their arrival and those who
were already
inside were cleared out
israeli police denied that there was any
age restriction
those who opposed the orders were
detained including
four from the islamic walk that oversees
the site
they were later released with conditions
tensions in occupied east jerusalem have
been running high since the beginning
of the month of ramadan in mid-april it
led to the 11 days war with gaza
um ahmed was filming a young man being
beaten up by police on april 28th
so bad that he had to be taken to
hospital with broken ribs
in the mayhem she didn't realize it was
her son ahmad
i only found out it was him after the
ambulance took him away
imagine i was filming and didn't realize
it was my own
son he's not a troublemaker when he sees
a soldier he walks off
he was sitting here on the steps he
didn't do anything
border guards are stationed in three
locations overlooking damascus gate
the main entrance to the old city here
tempers flare up at a short notice two
teenagers were held as we were standing
by
there was no apparent reason we saw them
as they were milling around
the guards refused to give us an
explanation but muhammad farah said they
were accused of throwing stones
everything is filmed here they didn't
throw anything the soldier told me they
didn't have an id
they will take them to the police
station and the parents can pick them up
from there
incidents like this happen several times
a day on a daily basis
and sometimes it's difficult to know why
for palestinians this is
part of a concerted effort to slowly
push them
out of their part of the city
palestinians consider
occupied east jerusalem as the capital
of their future state
despite president trump declaring it the
capital of israel
in 2017 since then
illegal settlements have expanded and
here in occupied east jerusalem
the settlers are more and more visible
in nearby several palestinian families
continue to be threatened with forced
expulsion
israeli police have blocked access to
the area to all non-residents
which means that mahal kurdi could only
see her friends briefly
under the watchful eye of the police
my friends came to visit but they're not
allowed past this checkpoint
but jews are allowed to move freely if
we go out we risk not being allowed to
come back home
so i speak to my friends from behind the
checkpoint
the cease-fire with gaza is holding but
it will remain a fragile one
as long as tensions continue to run high
in east jerusalem
al-jazeera in occupied east jerusalem